it's Wednesday time for our pet of the
week segment Danielle Harney with city
of Henderson is here with us and you
have an adorable little girl here all
right now she's unusual in that she's
called a micro bully tell us about
baroness and where she came from so
baroness is a micro bully it's kind of
like an English bulldog made with a
Frenchie made it with a little pity okay
she's about two years old and she came
from an illegal breeder in Henderson ah
and how did y'all discover her yeah so
the neighbors were very good and they
reported that there are some suspicious
activity going on and a lot of barking
was being heard from a property so our
Animal Control Officers investigated and
found her along with about 40 other dogs
on property oh my gosh what age is she
she's about two two she's a little
portly she is but she's so sweet and you
said she just wants to follow you around
and be loved and so if anyone's
interested in her what do they need to
know they need to know that because
because she was used for breeding she
really has pretty much lived her life in
a crate unfortunately so she's not potty
trained not super leash broken she will
walk okay on the harness but she'll trip
you up because she just wants to be next
to you so she's going to need a patient
family that can really teach her what
it's like to be a dog and not just
something that makes babies for people
her fees ninety dollars that includes
her spay we microchip and current on all
of her vaccines and the flowers in the
hair come with her they can yes hi baby
girl we'll get you a good home
if you're interested in adopting
baroness who was just absolutely
adorable call the city of Henderson
702-267-4970 or go to the website
cityofhenderson.com